Luzwin Madrid has traveled thousands of miles from Honduras
escaping poverty and violence.
She's spent most of the 7-week journey
walking with her 4-year-old daughter
and 15-year-old sister.
Her dream is to reach the U.S. to provide a better life for her family.
But now, she is one of thousands of migrants and refugees
stuck here in Tijuana,
camping just a few feet away from the fence that
divides Mexico and the United States.
Luzwin's brother was a 21-year-old cadet when he was hit and killed by a car.
Luzwin told us that the driver had previously threatened her brother for being in the military
and supporting the government.
She also says that anti-government groups have threatened her mother.
While on the road, Luzwin calls home a few times a week
to check on her family.
Luzwin sleeps in a tent on what is left of the Benito Juarez migrant camp.
After heavy rains flooded the area
Mexican authorities relocated most of its occupants.
But like many others, Luzwin has decided to stay.
Despite the harsher conditions, here she feels closer to the border,
to lawyers, to local organizations,
and closer to her goal:
getting asylum in the U.S.
She and thousands like her are waiting for their turn to be processed at the port of entry.
But the U.S. government only accepts a few dozen a day.
The city of Tijuana is cutting support in an attempt to shut down the camp.
Volunteers are not allowed to distribute clothes or food to the migrants inside the camp.
They must do it from the outside or find creative ways to sneak in supplies.
This is an improvised kitchen at a local shop.
Luzwin's sister, Elda, helps with the meals.
It rains again. Temperatures drop to the 30s at night.
Having a cold, fever and a cough is becoming the new norm in this part of Tijuana.
Luzwin's priority is to stay healthy and warm.
But not everyone manages to stay dry.
After a cold night, Luzwin gets ready to head to the Mexican immigration headquarters
to apply for a temporary work permit.
After the death of her brother and threats against her family,
Luzwin weighed her options and decided to embark on this journey.
Her dream is not only to get there,
but also to reunite with her daughters in the U.S.